Let us return to our problem from the intelligence test to see how generate and
test might apply as a problem solving method. Again, here is a problem that
we encountered earlier. Notice that this is a more complicated problem
than the guards and prisoners problem. Here is why. In case of the guards and
prisoner problem, each transformation from one state to another,
was a discrete transformation. One could take a certain number of guards to
the other side. One could take a certain number of prisoners to the other side,
or one could take a certain of number of guards and prisoners to the other side.
In this case, if I look at the approximation between A and B,
and I notice that the diamond inside the circle is now outside the circle and
is larger. Now suppose I were to try the same transformation from C
to D. So I can look at the circle inside the triangle,
put it outside, and also make it larger. I notice that when I put it outside,
I can put it outside right next to the triangle, a little bit farther,
a little bit farther, a little bit farther away. I can make it the same size, or
a little larger, or a lot larger. Increase its size by 50% or 51% or 52%.
So this space of possibilities here is very large. So for problems of this kind,
the need for a smarter generator and a smarter tester is critical,
because this space of possibilities can become very large, very quickly.